prince crollato uscire dalla gara così
ciao ragazzi un'ottima soluzione basso i
link ragazzi non so se ci sono
a breve partiamo stato che vi spieghiamo
che cosa anzi cosa non è successo per
lui abbiamo deciso di fare questa la
crif allora gianmarco né francia né come
ben 15 innanzitutto mi vende diciamo
ragazzi che leggiamo linea anche su
amici a entrare pagando richiamo è così
allora eccoci qua è così che si dicono
no da oggi il terribile posizione bianca
l'audio è terribile
e finita se l'audio è terribile ragazzi
si dimette ci sentite positivo ma
diventi sempre più fresca allora qui non
sono ragazzi se parliamo uno sopra
l'altro diventerà ancora più terribile
l'audio che datevi ho una domanda da
fare in tanto che vi benedico cos'è che
non si sente a b si sente novi si sente
ci hanno preso in giro noi cercheremo di
fare una pulizia sonora alla grande vi
giuro questi qui anche se può sembrare
altro è un paletto di mano santo allora
vorrei martino lanciare il link in modo
da evitare
ragazzi siamo partiti abbiamo anche lui
poteva partire se no ora stai facendo
ragazzi siamo in live
vi aspettiamo fate sul condito come
stanno scrivendo ragazze avvicinate ma
come era così
va bene i ragazzi allora iniziamo a
rallentamenti
come si parla c'è un modo per allentare
i momenti ma protezionistiche settore
non ci si parla sopra già quest in
italiano iniziamo appare certo capitando
a 16 anni non c'e niente
vabbè non sappiamo che cosa è male
ragazzetto nostra per l'hiv
vi spieghiamo però che cosa è successo
mentre di confino del santo
vorremmo volevamo fare un bel tom live e
questa line in realtà per quanto
desiderata involuta viene come quelle
redazioni che partono male ma cosa
persona giusta ora noi questa settimana
siamo convinti che una persona ci abbia
lanciato in una roccia
ma proprio un anatema un anatema
infinito dovevamo prendere un ufficio
alla fine pero denuncia dall'ufficio
stiamo facendo vari lavori ma se ne dica
dica come si diceva miti questo progetto
facciamo invitata live nel quale si
parla di malocchio sfiga l'ascolta
e lo facciamo tutti quanti insieme ok io
quello che mi chiedo è se il collega di
mandarmi alcuni audio su instagram
riapriremo a caso quindi dire quello che
vi pare ma quello che ci tengo a dirvi
che faremo un oretta di life
e che ogni tot tempo forse grandi e remo
forma ultima cosa oggi non dovevo uscire
questa live tantissimo quindi io direi
questo punto di partire e di iniziare a
parlare di quelli che sono stati alcuni
dei nostri problemi ma guglielmo
gallacci alto in mano alla tanto alla
pre questo mio amico che era andato tipo
in in america delle streghe questo corso
politica le riceve le politiche oppure
un po i ragazzi per le politiche in
questo momento lasciate entrare le
energie per tutta la stima che si
lanciano avvicina del microfono
se il microfono non vada momento ragazzi
come fare a lei
diciamo quindi con la nostra chiacchiera
più sia importante ufficio l'ufficio la
venia guglielmo chi per sei il nostro
avvocato tu che sei la persona che sa
cosa si può dire non so se questo
periodo ci sono persone regista credo
non si possa dire la molto bene grazie
ragazze diciamo che abbiamo riscontrato
delle difficoltà
[Musica]
come dire degli scogli e delle reticenze
da parte della controparte non abbocca
rendere così tipo tutto ma in realtà non
dico niente e niente ragazzi quindi
chiamo di nuovo alla ricerca anzi se
volete aiutarci e portarci ci pare una
grande idea mogli per entrare ragazze
el'aida non c'è non basta allora con
nostra somma fortuna in realtà è sarah
mi accingo a mettere i conti in pari
ma sembra certa cosa sindone ma non
d'occhio che cosa io tokyo tokyo
un modo per togliere il malocchio
ragazzi aspettate il ragazzo mi sta
chiamando sia perché sente inferiore
ogni giocatore perché stiamo parlando di
caldo vabbè denaro risponde vince mi
attaccano in faccia come me risponde al
telefono alla radice rivali ne scuso
allora ragazzi io poco prima da leggere
con timide che cos'è la tokyo verginiano
è stata un modo per togliere il
malocchio io voglio anche lo zoccolo
usato ea tutte le nostre petizioni sono
dicono cosa fatta tutti quanti insieme
ma veramente si stanno tirando fuori di
tutto ci stanno lanciando di tutto non
siamo semplici messaggi ragazzi ma che
già stanno arrivando
cercherò la mente di pc impossibile ciao
a tutti anche per conto di queste sfide
7 verità e mese prima di sostenere
l'esame
il mio ragazzo mi ha lasciata per
telefono dopo circa us penso possa stare
ma non madre ragazzi torno subito
ma come che ogni dubbio allora aspettate
scusate scusate
comunque questa ragazza città mi sento
che la gente
scusate ragazzi che ha fatto questo si
capisce che non abbiamo mai fatto cosa
diremo veramente perdonare per la vostra
pazienza
ok la nostra ok allora distrugge di
troppo
una settimana dopo per le mie amiche mi
mandasse a quel paese ottenuto sostenere
gli esami di preparazione esami dei
passaggi all'università è una settimana
può ancora ho dovuto fare i sistemi di
maturità diciamo che non è stato un mese
molto fortunato ciao covip dalla
pandemia che mi ha fatto nel giro di
fatto è stata mollata dal ragazzo e lo
sa fare un esame ma andate a cagare
dall'amico stanno studiando ieri l'esame
colombe gara aspettami che ti vengo a
prendere in macchina eliminano allora
continuiamo ad assen tirato i messaggi
ragazzi dove devo rilevare la gente fa
veramente fatica di vivere frasi fatte
un altro
ciao ciao anche a tutti gli altri
io superando la tua live in questo
preciso momento è proprio parlando di
sfiga perché non saprei come altro
definirla ti potrei dire che io sono a
casa in smart work i kit da 16 marzo
avrò ho lavorato due giorni sono tutti
quelli passate licenziarmi non sto
facendo capire facendomi stare a casa a
sono arrivata nella casa nuova che avevo
bloccato i lavori di ristrutturazione
causa co vide e mi si è rotto il vate
rooney si sono rotte due ante del box
doccia in vetro e non funziona il
portoncino del garage
quindi sì direi apposta una bomba è viva
ciao a tutti la mando un abbraccio
allora io durante questa quarantena
diventato riparatore dicessi formidabile
è vero non è vero
voi non avete toccato quello di sopra
alcuni di solo per quello di sotto di
poter stare di incaricare comunque nei
tuberi di manioca un pacchettino detto
vado tanto ma qualcosa deve assegnare lo
sa ma guarda ora tanto mi attendo con il
palo tanto allora io cosa che ha detto
ai pil marzo che cuore licenziarla è il
licenziamento psicologico che glielo sta
facendo capire che fatti concludenti
cittadine tra l'altro verrà poi non c'è
detto che lavoro fai bene questa tv non
ce ne tornavano fa alcun uso di capire
in che modo cioè la co2 monte come
funziona non è questo ma avrà un
dettaglio non è rilevante
ma questa cosa non ho mai ascoltato
messaggio ciao ciao ragazzi allora se
vogliamo parlare il malocchio almeno
mezzo milione gli ultimi tre mesi si è
rotta la lavatrice il forno il camino
pellet la macchina l'allarme di casa col
computer che fa casino e se continuiamo
così ci crolla la casa in testa quindi è
riusciti a toglierci ma occhio ci fa da
solo con canoni grazie saluti che rende
perché lo zero processi perché io io di
mia esperienza personale ragazzi in un
sol cui ho avuto anch'io dei problemi a
casa ma che sono dovuti solamente cioè a
me siamo allegato internazioni come sono
andato milano lasciato tutto acceso
perché l'andamento è scoppiato e il mio
vicino ha visto che mio qualcuno era
decreto per il nostro destino e lanciano
entrata di tacco e casa e quell'estate
non contento io ho altri sopra dice mai
di una finestra da tetto me ne sono
andato per un mese di vita sta lasciando
aperta quella è stata l'estate in cui a
roma per una settimana a grani minato
sente ripetere tutto a posto anche
l'unico elettrodomestico ragazzo io
voglio cogliere i getti di tutti e credo
me io lei appena lanciato non è vero io
sondaggi scooter a per eccellenza
parlando di voi quali sono tre distretti
comunque allora giammarino il coso 22
luglio in esame william cina si sta qui
all'uscita di poter mandare i vostri
vocali bravo bravo bravo bravo allora
ciao ciao ragazzi sto guardando da ed è
passata stagione in cura il giuro che
non saprei
questo per dire così sono scomode per
fare del turismo spicciolo invece di qua
derivato da mediano altri ciao boom che
ha la linea giammarco del record la
sfigata posso essere io che a tre mesi
dalla laurea
nonostante fessi sempre andando bene ho
toccato due importanti dove ho studiato
tantissimo ed essi affidate mino nello
studiare
che sfiga ciao gente
ci può cioè ci può essere sfiga un esame
al di là della preparazione esistono al
di là della preparazione
l'esame è secondo me 80 per cento puro
10 15 per cento preparazione sottostante
5 per cento che è la componente di ansia
panico sfiga come dite di cogli italiani
anche perché ti permettere umano del per
quanto possa essere super obiettivo è
comunque essere sterilizzati qui secondo
me io le credo
tesoro andrà meglio sente touch
sostenuti di nuovo
il ragazzo aveva mandato un audio dove
si era visto la partita allo stadio e
c'era così tanto con tizio in curva non
lo so che l'ha firmato come esaminatore
esempio senza essere al top e in quello
proprio la ragazza allora già amici
arrivano delle cose interessanti già
allora chiedono se la linea vuoi di dare
di scrittura del braccio che il braccio
che ti fanno ragazzo ma andate ragazzi
una di quelle cose che non faccio mai
l'esposizione mediatica sempre si vede
ciao a tutti
allora parlando di stieg e io dovevo
dare l'esame della patente o acciaio
me l'hanno rinviato due volte per il
corona quindi dopo che è tipo 2 anni e
mezzo tre che sono escono guida mendy
sfigati così non si pone una cosa
tranquilla io ho fatto l'esame teorico
almeno 56 con te cosa si è stato possa
poi ora me la vivo come visto come ma
che fa seriamente questore di seduta
cinque stati che la teoria tu hai
superandola 60 x culo
no era diventato così bravo penso di
aver fatto meno tre errori è stato
difficile dai primi esami solo applicato
poco però poi ho cominciato ad applicare
poi ce l'ho fatta perché forse lo vuole
le cose che erano ragazzi non
dimenticano mai è invece su l'esame
sulla patente
si sa che teoria che pratica ho avuto un
pò imbarazzante
io sud pacifico
gli ho fatto i test piccoli invece di
stare se liberi ai test che online
mi siedo in comincia ad esserci il
monotipo quando bisogna unire il
parabrezza quando ogni settimana quando
è così cioè quelle cose che ti ci sono
fatte del fare pazzie
io ho messo credo 9 11 risposte perché
avevo tenuto per la fine persone
arrivano così a capena ho fatto ho uno
quello che l'ho presa cioè io sono un
attore passato a capitatami si impenna e
pareggia fatto il primo esame e 5 errori
bocciato se non le sanno è che mi sto
preparando la stessa preparazione
promosso 4 errori una persona positiva
anche noi
avversario siamo stati certo punto non
faccio passare il pedone e le stranieri
mi dice ma di belle giocate a scacchi e
io non avendo in qualche rossi spendendo
per il culo arrestato deciderebbe cose
vanno benissimo per prender del tempo
come accelerato messo la cura dietro la
jeep che mi fa è fenomeno oggi subito
dopo mi sacra erano all'inizio ragazzi
non dorme precedenza si è infatti co
quando bisogna a quanti metri sono nata
io e messi non c'è non ci sono dei neri
è un occhio dagli cominciato a parlare
di filosofia e lui parlava parlava io il
cambio ad udine con il pubblico
ha preso lo sono io a sentire
testimonianze delle persone non ho mai
così e ore di cucina hanno aspetta
vogliamo cambiare passiamo a domande e
risposte ragazzino abbiamo dirà il
pranzo che abbiamo messo da parte perché
c'erano totali giusto perché ci arrivato
di prima che ne è anche uno dei motivi
per cui abbiamo fatto tardi mi dà
fastidio se non parliamo di mangiare
prendere le cose seguendo la diretta e
siete bellissimi serie bravissimi
innanzitutto allora proposito di sfiga
quest'anno ad agosto avevo prenotato un
viaggio dieci giorni prima che
scoppiasse la pandemia e dove andare in
cina a marzo dovevo andare a londra a
trovare i miei amici che siano
trasferirli e non soprattutto andare
perché c'è stata appunto la pandemia
sempre marzo doveva iniziare il
tirocinio tanto atteso per poi poter
conseguire la laurea ma è stato bloccato
tutto sempre a causa della pandemia e
niente per il momento a e il concerto a
giugno dere dolci di peppers
bloccato sempre per la pandemia quindi
speriamo che possa terminare al meglio
quest'anno bacio a tutti e siete
fortissimi
[Musica]
organizziamo il rapporto di un bancale
di pesanti a casa tua che altro
conoscevi di matty col teatro di legno
per casa che possa in qualche modo
purificare le energie ragazzi allora
fatto di una cosa è meglio andrà tutto
bene poi il consumatore
ciao ragazzi sicuramente il mio
messaggio ne ho perso nella marea di
messaggi distorti di ricevendo però
voglio raccontarvi la mia sfida durante
questa quarantena e cioè che è a fine
febbraio è scaduto il mio contratto di
tirocinio e dovevo fare il passaggio al
contratto di apprendistato soltanto che
è successo quello che è successo il co
ed è quindi abbiamo rimandato e in tutto
ciò io ho lavorato durante la quarantena
senza neanche poi percepire il bonus per
chi ha lavorato durante l'emergenza e in
tutto ciò mi è toccato anche uno
stipendio piemonte virgolettiamo l'hanno
ridotto perché lo giriamo che ho
lavorato di meno
purtroppo però da una mia drappello
dalle trovate ragazzi tutti
al momento però vede anche siamo tutti
sulla stessa che sarà anche a tutti
quella pancetta la cultura e l'identità
con questo canale nuzzo facciamo
informazione su questa italia che tocca
sino al telefono cibo in mano va bene
mangia dove perde molto appetito anche a
me grazie in usa re quando sono attesi
manettari con una rete è lì tutti fanno
19 con tremonti sulla netta rivolta pure
il salewa ha lanciato m quale il periodo
è quello no non lanciate sale per casa
mia ci poniamo canale è tale solo se lo
fai avere delitto ragazzo si confonde ma
incrociarli perché hanno acqua e olio si
vabbè adesso tutti gli elementi della
terra sotto questa rimedi scientifici
io sono chiedo però se gianmarco che
succede a parare politi colpo aspetto
non sempre non le ha proprio il mese
quando era questo e di lavinia questo
mio
si no io mangio dopo perché sfogo che io
credo
anche perché l'ho chiesto di prendere
appuntamento di condizione
io invece ho una bellissima di studenti
per malocchio proprio recente ovvero che
la ditta dove lavoro mi ha visto mi ha
lanciato il malocchio ne sono
sicurissima perché mi ha guardato in un
modo veramente meschino
dopodiché io me lo sono sempre addosso
la mia collega che lo sa toglie che mi
ha visto che avevo il malocchio mela ha
tolto e poi li cosa strana che gli orari
sono coincisi con il fatto che per quel
periodo la salva che avevo prenotato
infor degna per quest'estate mi avevano
cancellato la prenotazione e poi ridata
la protezione quando la mia
che mi ha accolto il malocchio cioè che
devo dire questa persona scrive adesso
sinistra che l'hanno parla di possiedo
nell'atto di questa professione di l'ho
colpito
grazie che abbiamo fatto finora credo
che buon appetito e allora come fate a
che disciplina mente alba d'occhio
domanda dal web
prima no ragazzi no no ci crediamo che
meriti il cicr e diamo perché siamo del
sud e al sud si crede molto le cose
io so io credo molto nelle energie che
mandano le persone
vero è che ci siano persone che piccoli
bene persone che fanno male i migliori
auguri
esistono amici che noi reputiamo amici
perché non sono dei rompi emotivi e ti
fanno star male
le persone che magari fanno sì che siano
guarda io non mi alzo inchieste ha fatti
solo perché fare schizzare che nel tempo
si sono messi sente meno cosa io l'ho
fatto niente questo avvio delle
modifiche che non ne andrà meglio la
grande regalo
ciao volare basso non sento voi in
guardina sotto si sente stressato
il palo santo ragazzo
ecco qua ecco qua un secondo me non va
meglio
o meglio noi allora sempre su instagram
a ragazzi stanno arrivando vocali per
sfortuna o raccontare di un aneddoto che
mi è successo sulla sfiga in quanto mio
suocero ha portato un mio curriculum ma
una persona per farmi lavorare il giorno
dopo con la persona è morta
[Musica]
io ho un amico che finalmente privato
kawaii elmo ciao ragazzi ciao wood
doccia soprattutto la vigna sono
innamorati da molto tempo su un piccolo
particolare interesse per farvela breve
io a settimana prossima sarei dovuto
partire per la puglia una settimana
degli amici le mani sono a casa mia però
purtroppo ieri andato a correre le mie
parti del menisco del ginocchio destro
fini sono abbastanza convinto che la
colpa della mia ex ragazza che mi ha
lasciato il giorno prima quindi come si
dice il napoletano cornuti e mazziati
si sentiva come disco disco crisi meglio
progetti di manico benissimo adesso come
taxi con una ragazza di camucia ospiti
vi vedo la mia figlia ha avuto inizio il
14 di gennaio di quest'anno dopo che
dove lavoravo in una caduta riposo sono
mancate 2 signora cui io tenevo
tantissimo l'alienato sempre peggio mi è
morto il gatto
non ho superato gli esami all'università
problemi solite con i ragazzi ormai odio
e poi tanto da cambiare la pandemia
la sessione estiva il caldo chi più ne
ha più ne metta
ciao a tutti però di essere affinata
nell'ultimo periodo con immobili io ho
35 anni quindi non so se può essere
fonte di contrazione e comunque come
visto in faccia
grazie ragazzi anche modesta essere
aggiornati andrà meglio
considerazioni sugli uomini ragazzi meno
tempo cerca di piacere gli atti di tempo
l'accecante cioè se stessi non vendete
sogni ma solide realtà sono stanco di
cercare di piacere alla gente per quello
che non sono molto marino e acer e per
quello che sei così come stare sul caso
del bologna che bello previste di
professioni
allora andiamo a chi non so se
trasformati momento non sa che mangiano
che è buono ragazzi farlo bisogna
mandare un ragazzo che direzione dare a
questa diretta non lo sto dicendo mi ha
mai detto perché mi dava l'idea era
quella di fare tre forma
credo che ci state prendendo gusto
boiate vogliamo continuare questa via
claudia non è ora tiriamo pubblico da
bravo continuare con continuiamo con
vietata o andiamo verso tipologie
rotella chiediamo un pochino domande e
risposte risposte
vediamo invece cosa si dice oppure ci
vedete mentre mangiarlo private di
battuta la dipartita testi sia quindi ai
motel grazie della tua vita testate come
ribaltiamo una linea quando a new york
era il cellulare odiate ciao cuccia
ospiti vi vedo la mia figaro ciao ciao
ciao ragazzi allora
premetto la mia famiglia è originaria di
giu di salerno mia nonna crede molto
queste cose
e ogni volta che stavo male da piccolino
avevo questo mal di testa e non si
capiva il perché mio nonno vi ne va lui
faceva dei segni in testa delle croci
intanto che intanto ripeteva questa
questa filastrocca questa poesia anti
malocchio
purtroppo non mi ricordo con le facesse
però su chi iniziava dicendo con questa
ronca che ogni male stronca che è
dannato
vabbè se c'è qualcuno in chat che la sa
la scriva per favore perché non mi
ricordo una donna non se la ricorda
scusa mimì è partito il dito funzionava
c'è stavo bene non so se effetto placebo
qualcosa del genere funziona
in memoria di custodio sentiti bravo
bravo bravo in aula ciao goccioline
mitcham rico è certo ma per togliere il
malocchio bisogna mettere 200 grammi di
sale dietro alle porte di casa oppure
sopra alcuni mobili è un tacking che mi
ha insegnato mia nonna quando ero molto
piccolo e quando praticamente riteniamo
che ci fosse qualche finto maligno pure
qualche persona che mandava energie
negative verso di me e niente ogni sfida
mettere sale ovunque
a quanto pare non ha funzionato però
potete provare magari sono io che son
cazzi sua ma mandato un messaggio molto
merino legato ma cosa sta succedendo
sono cazzi suoi
ciao a tutti i ragazzi ciao bulldog sole
grande grande allora il mio metodo è
legato diciamo un famoso
corriere italiano e ogni volta che vedo
i suoi furgoncini puntualmente li vedo
per strada insomma o non mi passa
l'autobus o migrate qualcosa può essere
cellulare soldi biglietto qualsiasi cosa
in campo nel marciapiede ma questa cosa
ormai non succede solo a me manca mia
sorella a mio papà magari lui e macchina
avete un furgoncino poi non trova
parcheggio cose del genere non si sa da
quando è cominciata questa cosa però è
fatto sta che oggi è ancora così
per la gioia della nostra famiglia e
vabbè andrà tutto bene diciamo così ciao
a tutti ragazzi un abbraccio a grattarti
quando passa davvero e disegnatore non
permetta che l'hotel 33 anni non ho mai
sentito cosa sapevo non sapesse cosa
tassata insidiosa ma poi una storia di
mutuo ciao ragazzi ciao a tutti
allora io ho comprato casa l'anno scorso
la dovevo comprare a maggio e il
proletario doveva lasciarla ad agosto ci
sono state una serie di impicci
burocratici per cui poi l'ho dovuta
comprare a luglio e quindi lui ha deciso
che mai avrebbe lasciato a novembre
dovevano cominciare lavori a dicembre ma
la ditta ha avuto un problema per cui
sono cominciate a febbraio
dovevano finire a fine marzo ma c'è
stata la pandemia luglio 2000 mente
ancora non ci sono entrata perché
ovviamente tutto ciò che avevo comprato
nel frattempo tipo cucina bagno camera
da letto eccetera non ancora arrivato e
in tutto questo a novembre factoring con
i miei perché la casa con presentiamo
alla mia compagna ed è stato tutto
fantasticamente meravigliosamente
inutile perché ancora non ci andiamo
[Risate]
almeno è l'amore che il mio padre una
roba non da poco anche costituente luna
niente io ok passiamo per andare peggio
ciao ragazzi guardate a proposito di
sfiga ieri stavo facendo gli esami on
line e io faccio ad accademia di belle
arti quindi è già a fare di esame online
per l'accademia di belle arti è un po
una creata però vabbè lasciamo stare
mi ero preparata tutta una bellissima
presentazione rappresentare questo mio
progetto video arte tutto è praticamente
successo che non so come mai il video
che avevo messo all'interno della
presentazione
online non funzionava e quindi sono
andata a cercare il mio video sul
computer
il problema cosa è successo che io
all'interno della cartella lungo messo
tutti i miei progetti di per
l'università è successo che c'erano
anche delle mie foto nuda per un
progetto sotto grasso poterlo il fatto e
diciamo che durante la mia coach st una
ragazza che il messaggio 800 volte ma la
catania leggi qui sta gran cosa
descritto completo come ti chiami inter
amala catania prova bara assolutamente
lavorarlo descritto perché sai dal dott
allora ma ancora indicato no ragazzi io
devo sapere sta ragazza con gli disse
vibrano il e grosso cioè non mi ha
mandato e mi così stanotte io rimango
qua e tu non ci venisse di mandare il
messaggio
[Musica]
9 in pratica è successo che il mio
professore tutti i miei compagni di
corsa anche il tecnico informatico hanno
visto le mie foto nuda
vabbè lasciamo stare l'imbarazzo cercato
di fare finta di niente ma è sceso un
silenzio impressionante e poi va bene
l'esame è andato bene però non so se
ringraziare il mio video o il mio corpo
[Musica]
allora dobbiamo rispondere anche scrive
sono leggi qui sta graumann noi sul mare
patina preparare il pasto di gennaro che
non sia pratici per niente vediamo
obiettivo è il messaggio arriva la pasta
che nella prova messaggi ma la gente non
mangi braico messaggi la più felice
funziona bene
preferiamo non per niente non sono nella
trattativa non si insegna allora
malanotti minare è vero solo un
discepolo può ascoltare riparte dal
malocchio e si chiude in una stanza
delle persone un oggetto a battere della
personalità di malocchio non sono che
fisicamente sia possibile quindi queste
filastrocche bisogna essere anche la
notte di natale di impararla sei mesi
ventiquattro ragazzi che scrivono mia
madre porta sfiga agli animali ciao
ragazzi quando questo messaggio contesa
raccontarvi una mia sfida particolare
non che io sia particolarmente fortunato
ma per incontrarvi degli episodi che
sono accaduti e che vedono come
protagonista mia madre che però è
portatrice di sfida purtroppo credo per
gli altri e soprattutto per gli animali
una volta mia madre è contento del mio
vicino di casa si lascia andare ad un
complimento disse che vengo questo
coniglio praticamente il giorno dopo lo
trovarono fantastico e forse nella
stessa settimana una settimana dopo mia
madre video e un cagnolino passeggiata
insieme al suo padrone per il paese e
mamma facendo dei complimenti a questo
cagnolino poi andò via
in quei giorni dopo scoprimmo che questo
taglierino ero morto affogato che era
caduto del perché era caduto nel porto
del paese e quindi non credo che mia
madre abbiamo un buon rapporto con gli
animali
ciao a tutti
secondo la doppiatrice ammettendo
comunque ragazzi passano così da
galatina moretta passava rompe questo
che metteranno tutti abbondantemente
rotti e manga trecco a matisse che si
strutturato meglio non lo sento con un
tema che magari forse ce ne è più e non
somali erano veramente difensore anche
noi siamo ragazzi fateci avere qua sotto
materni veramente delle dritte a parte a
livello tecnico che magari audio
migliore
una ripresa che possiamo fare migliore
un audio migliore tutto quanto migliore
se ci sono magari dei temi che potesse
trattare in questo modo se ci sono i
consigli per migliorare l'effetto la
parte di prodotti dalle giornate la
prossima volta
insomma fatecelo sapere perché qualsiasi
cosa ci potrebbe permettere di
migliorare se questo chiacchieroni priva
di permettere di migliorare se queste
monitorare questa voce di tenere a mano
sul fuoco ragazze
vogliamo farne un ultimo giro matto
ultimo connetto sono anche se ci
scrivono credo che battere la ragazza
che è stata vista viva da tutta
l'università sia impossibile
assolutamente esperienze paranormali e
tirocini ecco dunque minori calciare da
questa storico marco si può immaginare
fuori campo e quindi un esperienza
paranormale quale e quanta ne hanno
premiato che non fa che cosa stiamo per
l'intrattenimento queste altro giro
allora esperienze paranormali
facciamo un pollo su wii sta che è
ragionato in poco alcuno ma parecchio
infatti puntato su che cosa possiamo
farlo temi vecchi temi nuovi mettiamoci
qualcosa
tornando al mare con vitamina l'occhio
due ragazzi che ora quindi non faremo
mai un espediente di fuori strambe e poi
molto simile esperienza per la loro
madre
da oggi premonitori io penso
ma canzoni di una ragazzina
vai alla fine val masino ragazzi
perdonateci se questa rai avuto dei
problemi dei problemi mi chiamo marco
capitoli diamo scusa abbiamo cercato di
non bucare anche la giornata di oggi nel
quale lo cercando di fare un qualcosa di
carino e anche nuovo perché oggi si è
dovuto uscire un altro video ma la sfiga
la settimana si è preso un pochino di
mira quindi abbiamo fatto una cosa nuovo
insieme ed è bello sperimentare si fanno
valere come questo caso di razza del
piaciuto molto quindi avevo chiesto
fateci sapere se vi potrebbe interessare
il futuro
un format live strutturali meglio con
meno problemi tecnici che dire non ci
vediamo domenica in una punta per noi
forse cercavano merita cucina buttata
via ticino per spegnere acuto ma il cui
dovere
ciao ciao ragazzi da te lo sguardo premi
quello bravo
ciao termina